o que é um desafio pra você acho que
cada um pode fechar os olhos ou então
pensar só a cabecinha aí o que é um
desafio pra você o meu desafio eu posso
contar pra vocês foi aprender a fazer
chuquinha de cabelo
ok juquinha de cabelo sim
esse foi meu desafio o desafio foi
tentar entender como fazer uma lacinho
que era redondo transformar o cabelo eu
não sabia fazer isso eu perdia muito
tempo tentando afetar o cabelo e aí eu
gastava tempo passava o tempo eo cabelo
ficava assim desse jeito
tadinha da minha filha é a mariana e
suspende as que eu fazia nela mas eu ia
sair com ela pior se espantaria dinheiro
sempre os cabelos formados
assim o nível diferente digamos assim
mas de repente quando ia para uma festa
junina dava certo
enfim gente é bom eu também tem o pedro
está no meu colo ali nessa foto
e há mais ou menos um ano e três meses
atrás eu me tornei pai em dobro porque
papai em dobro gente
o primeiro painel por ser pai de duas
crianças e criar lá sozinho
papai em dobro porque teve um dia que eu
estava no meu trabalho e e de repente
recebi um telefonema da minha esposa e
eu falei pra ela ela falou a moça nem
pra casa
era uma sexta feira 7 10 à noite mais ou
menos eu falei assim olha o negócio aqui
do meu trabalho eu já toquei acabando
resolver chat ligo bom tempo passou de
us 50 minutos mais ou menos
ela me ligou de novo e ela falou assim é
bom já que você não me ligou já que você
não retornou a chamada e você não está
me dando atenção eu vou deixar as
crianças à mãe e vou para academia
pratica muay thai que eu gosto
toc toc tranqüilo as coisas rápidas fui
para minha casa foi pra casa da minha
sogra perdão pegar as crianças devem ir
à casa de banho de comida sempre um
paliativo simples muita coisa assim
banho comida e ele brincando com eles
para não voltar
de repente me liga é importante que o
senhor
aqui na academia agora exposição está
muito bem é importante que o senhor
venha eu falei ok tudo bem com ela não
eu vir aqui pra gente conversar a gente
olha tudo né a minha sogra ficar com as
crianças e corri lá na academia
chegando lá olhando assim a primeira
visão que eu vejo são as pessoas
encostadas na parede chorando aqui na
frente do tatame
e olha que eu chego na festa também
totalmente eu vejo que tem um corpo
coberto começou a minha esposa ela cabia
havia acabado de falecer por uma parada
cardíaca
ela não tomava remédios ela é uma pessoa
saudável
tinha uma linha de são roque simpático
esportes e precisamos em dia é o porquê
disse não sei não sei explicar isso
a única coisa disso é por não saber
explicar é que essas coisas não têm
explicação
e aí cabe a mim aceitar ea aceitar isso
eu entendido que eu tenho que vir ao
papa em dobro porque eu terei que voltar
para casa cuidar de duas crianças a
partir daquele momento e ser um pai
diferente um pai muito mais indicado um
parque
acima de qualquer coisa poderia
transformar a situação
meu irmão chegou na academia - algumas
uns minutos depois de me dar um abraço
chorando e eu falei pra ele chamou de
negão é meu irmão de casa e sem cara de
novo isso com a gente com cara de novo
quando era adolescente perdeu o pai na
frente de casa por um acidente de carro
mas meu pai não residente de carro na
frente da nossa casa e ele estava lá
naquela situação de novo estou vivendo
uma tragédia dessa vez vai pedir sim
cara dessa vez não mano
dessa vez não saber que eu faço essa
história está diferente quero fazer e
ressignificar esse negócio não vou
deixar as crianças passarem ficarem
tristes ou ficar até depressivos como
naquela época eu pedi um pai fiquei
então eu tratei de cuidar desse fator
com as crianças e no quinto dia depois
do aparecimento das coisas acontecendo
você vai cuidar de documentação aquelas
coisas todos os trâmites que vocês já
sabem a minha meu filho falou assim
papai porque é uma nota vindo daí que o
óleo foi assim meu deus
é preciso contar pra eles no outro dia
de manhã
botei o parque parque barigui em
curitiba e todo mundo conhece
coloquei o peru numa perna maria na
outra e comecei a explicar filho
sabe aquele bichinho de repente morre
então depois um cachorrinho 21 11 no
elefante os objetos maiores
então isso é morte eles morreram filho
foi o que aconteceu com a mãe a mãe
morreu a mãe for à copa disse ao
fifa.com tudo é pesada falar para uma
criança isso né
parece pesado mas era que eu tinha que
fazer era que eu tinha que fazer porque
falar sobre morte é um tabu
as pessoas não entendem muito isso e
falar que para uma criança que a mãe
morreu era a maneira de proteger ele
porque 15 dias depois já estava na
escola e quando de potássio na escola os
amigos eles viam assim
pedro e foi tanta que ela morreu opção
preparar essa criança para responder
isso não só na escola mas o resto da
vida
então eu falei as coisas que têm de ser
faladas da maneira que eu achava claro
se falado pra que ele crescesse forte e
pudesse junto comigo ressignifica e
conta uma história positiva disso
bom enfim esse dia foi um dia muito
importante na minha vida um dos mais
importantes porque o peru e perguntou
papai mas porque o policial faz isso
fifa nem filho pode ser um escolhe
pessoas especiais para morar com ele em
uma manhã em uma delas por isso é uma
coisa com papai do céu mas ela queria
estar aqui que você não foi uma escolha
dela
isso aconteceu mas a gente vai viver bem
filha o que ele começou a chorar foi o
parque ele passou um pouquinho e já
começou a brincar com a irmã dele na
grama eu respirei aliviado então peguei
as duas crianças e fui pra casa abrir a
porta coloquei no chão
na minha casa tem filhos agora somos nós
três
ao fazer isso pedro correu por sofá a
mariana começando pela casa durante um
ano e dez meses a 1 ano e 10 meses a um
ano e 28 dias tinha acabamos de feita a
festa de um ano dela ea mariana então
começou uma mãe manhã entrando nos
ambientes da casa até que ela citou a
palavra mãe
e ao fazer isso ela despertou insight
mim de que eu dê como eu construí uma
história positiva que estava querendo
buscar quando ela fez isso eu achei foi
bem nos olhos delas um baque na frança
fiquei agarrado com ela e falei filha
aonde quer que a mãe esteja ela está
muito orgulhosa de você está muito feliz
e pior filha ela tirando sarro de mim
porque a gente estava disputando aqui em
que ela fala primeiro papai e mamãe e
ela ganhou nova mamãe e eu passei a ser
chamado de uma mãe por sete meses
chegava na escola mamãe mamãe mamãe
chega no mercado mamãe
então por sete meses a ouvir e mamãe com
o chamava de mãe ou seu pai uma mãe não
importa mas por 76 foi chamado já o
chama de papai
mas foi chamado então gente a partir daí
comecei significa todas as histórias
essa história eu comecei a criar um
ambiente muito positivo muito feliz
muito alegre com essas crianças
crescerem
eu sofria claro que sofreu bastante
passava por tantas dificuldades
geralmente ficava muito triste observar
muitas histórias incríveis que eu vivi
com eles índice de de transformar as
coisas mas eu comecei a mergulhar na
paternidade na sociedade uma maneira
muito mais profunda e comecei a perceber
que as pessoas tinham sim que ser
curadas
a sociedade estava segurada porque todo
mundo acha que é uma dificuldade vem já
fica depressivo triste olhando e nas
oportunidades e nas dificuldades que nós
encontramos oportunidades
ninguém é feliz ninguém é tão forte
ninguém é rápido como diz o ditado não
se fazem bons marinhos em mares calmos e
nessa hora que vi uma coisa difícil você
falar assim aqui tal por não aprender é
agora e eu comecei a usar pra vida e eu
fazer isso mas se perceber que a
sociedade tá precisando assim de uma
cura porque hoje as pessoas têm muito de
pressão
a média nacional de depressão é 5.8 por
cento do brasil no mundo a média de
pressão e 4.4 população
além disso gente não sabemos nada sobre
depressão brasileiro sabe muito pouco e
é doença mental mais impactante do
momento e nós aqui na américa latina o
brasil é o país mais ansioso
dez por cento da população ansiosa
a gente tem que fazer coisas para
melhorar essas nessas vantagens agentes
essas problemas que nós temos
certo a gente não tomar cuidado da saúde
não comer alimentos saudáveis para ficar
bem fisicamente mas o que a gente faz
comente nada quando tem um problema você
já sai chorando
não podemos reagir assim já estudam
todas com a sociedade vai entender mas
quem é que mais precisa de ajuda os
homens gente por que homem não chora
capaz homem não pode o psicólogo e
perguntar fala dos sentimentos porque
isso vai deixar frágil homens item
se não tem coragem sotaque de sines
tablado ele é um covarde ou sem escutado
ele não é regina porrada na violência
ele é fraco né
enquanto os homens aqui não viram isso
quando criança e continuo ouvindo e nós
homens que não querendo fazer alguma
coisa diferente da sociedade que vamos
buscar referências ficamos perdidos nos
encontramos esse tipo de homem é difícil
não que todos sejam assim
isso me leva a dizer pra vocês que hoje
94 por cento dos homicídios são feitos
acontece com os homens homem se suicida
quatro vezes mais que a mulher ou seja
70% dos suicídios gente
além disso a maior taxa de homicídio de
crimes contra o filme quando o feminismo
são os homens que cometem
além de ser as maiores vítimas de
trânsito a maior população do sistema
carcerário certo
imagina se um homem fala que o outro o
meu sincero só um amigo que você é
bonito que você é bonito o que vão dizer
de mim eu sou e aí porque tinha um outro
homem bonito pelo amor de deus
certo se eu não sei não sei quantificar
se não tivermos inúmeras mulheres não
consegue provar a minha masculinidade
gente que isso então eu tenho que ter
várias mulheres para provar que
realmente meus amigos ou bonfada pior na
roda de amigos tomar minha cervejinha a
esposa liga pra ir pra casa porque tem
alguma coisa lá e eu vou que ficaram
falar mas é o tal do pm neto do pau
mandado porque o chamou
a casa não gente eu tenho aqui a minha
família o que é mais importante que
valores nós estamos colocando para a
sociedade e eu não quero a sociedade ver
meus filhos e eu comecei a fazer isso
com meu filho porque olha só veja se um
filme um homem visto esse vídeo aqui
o que os homens iriam pensar eu sou um
pai que carregam que leva o filho do
parque num carrinho cor de rosa filho
carrega leva carregando uma boneca
meu nome é você cara que eu e você que
se chama o filho nesse dia
logicamente que eu encontrei alguns
homens que meu olhar é normal mas muito
melhor que os olhos arregalados meu que
você está fazendo que o filho para o
telefone preparando para brincar no
parque com carrinho cor de rosa maria
boneca dentro quando cheguei cá está
criando o filho homossexual que se quer
com a sociedade
então gente entende que a cidade precisa
de cura e que muito de estar com os
homens não vão abrir diálogos entre os
homens a gente resolver essa parada
certo nós precisamos educar nossos nova
sociedade a maneira que esse equilíbrio
de géneros seja a solução para resolver
muitos problemas sociais que nós temos
além disso a gente tem uma história
compartilhar com vocês que um dia estava
em casa e a gente tem que dar valores
para lidar com os valores mais corretos
momentos então limpeza da cozinha detido
limpo com uma coisa fantástica o negócio
assim a esposa falar comigo uma coisa
que é uma bagunça toda a boca o balcão
assim né então as coisas e olhando cara
passou dez motos não está nem quando
voltou foi minha esposa poxa cara que
respeito do amor se mantinha tudo sujo
que limpá
ela pegou eu não vou me importar com sua
chatice não eu escolho ser feliz e não
vou me importar essas pequenas coisas
que foi atá né até parece que é assim e
ser feliz é uma tomada de decisão é uma
escolha
a gente tempo passou e eu digo pra vocês
ele estava certa e ser feliz sim é uma
escolha né
a gente fica esperando que a vida a
gente conquistar um carro uma casa uma
viagem internacional uma roupa nova para
se regozijar de felicidade enquanto ser
feliz mesmo não é isso não é isso
se eles têm outras coisas que a gente
fala da economia do dinheiro a gente
fala economia do tempo e hoje também se
fala da economia atenção porque você tem
um tablet ou celular televisão as
pessoas não se tem que dá atenção para
tudo então se quer economizar até
atenção mas eu quero sugerir que um novo
tipo de economia
a economia de coisas irrelevantes
economia daquilo que não é relevante
para sua vida quando você tá ali
nesse dia a dia olhando o pão que ficou
o farelo até perdendo tempo com coisas
que não vão fazer a vida é diferente
gente uma toalha em cima da cama uma
tampa do vaso levantar da gente é muito
pequeno perto do que a felicidade que a
vida tem a não vai ser feliz e se
regularizar com um passarinho na janela
quando o pouso
caramba casa é muito difícil eu nem
consegue captar isso todo dia mas agora
se você economiza aquela pessoa chata
que fica te falar um monte de coisa o
trabalho que você não quer ouvir você
economiza aquele momento encara o chievo
tempo existem mais casos a segunda etapa
depois de ser feliz aqui um pouquinho
sabe essas coisas que a vida são
pequenas e que trapalhão no dia-a-dia de
você viver bem
esquece que ela faça economia daquilo
que é irrelevante e seja feliz
seja feliz você pode escolher isso você
pode escolher isso tem olha para trás e
veja todas as orações para fazer o que
você fez hoje e receba isso que você é
aceite muito no seu autoconhecimento dê
um google naquilo que você já viveu e
traga à tona agora para coisas que você
precisa viver
além disso gente celebra se eleve eu vou
lembrar que você só aprende e faz e
chiquinho de cabelo você leva todo dia
que eu perdi três quilos de cabelo sabe
por quê
olha a última foto que está mais em pé
então caros e têm agora já sei fazer que
em cabelos e levo isso
além disso lembrou várias coisas e
celebrar a importante de se contar a
vocês porque uma vez eu fui lá mercado
passando em vinho sempre quis comprar um
em promoção de um bom vinho em casa
moura que o vinho comprei taça que é o
dia que foi jantar numa especial que
leva esse vinho
ela é claro que aí vem um jantar
especial em abril face vamos levar esse
fim
além do mais baratinho né de hoje e
depois a gente apresentar para um outro
lugar que aceitava royale fritar onde
levavam não vamos levar esse dinheiro
não deixa por um momento
enfim gente dois anos se passaram e
ouvindo ficou na adega uma gavetinha que
eu coloco quando eu fui arrumar as
coisas para uma viagem de 15 dias depois
que ela tinha falecida eu abrir o
armário houve quem estava lá e fiquei
tão indignado tão indignado indignada
eu fui jantar noite peguei aquele vinho
levei para casa do meu sogro por causa
do roberto tamari que vem agora vai ter
mais o tom e se vinha cargo garante que
vamos comer pão tomando vinho ver vamos
tomar e cidinho cara a gente tomou
aquele vinho e desde então aprendi que
celebrar importante cara se lembrar
diariamente faz mais feliz mas mais
alegre
celebre a normalidade das coisas no
espelho e esperando uma coisa me
acontecer você deve acreditar naquela
linha de trabalho humano que deu certo
que lá na frente vai te dá a promoção
não se deve só promoção e celebrar faz a
gente feliz e continue se lembrando que
nem a gente está na dificuldade a gente
está mostrando que é possível ser feliz
entendendo que um rei significado de uma
coisa ruim vai fazer a sua vida sim ser
feliz nós podemos pôr significa que eu
só peço que a gente faça um novo pro
momento de hoje ea gente traga boas
energias é urgente
[Aplausos]